on prend l'avion direction l'Asie pour
découvrir la nouvelle tendance des
influenceurs chinois une mode qui
consiste à aller se prendre en photo
dans les cafés façon Siri dire des cafés
au mur de brique éclater pour faire
effet bombardement comme si on était
allé pour Damas sauf qu'ici on veut
juste faire exploser c'est là il
faudrait vraiment qu'un T2 tous les
codes de triche
[Musique]
Emmanuel son fils et Vanessa ta nièce
merci
les enquêteurs explique que les
policiers municipaux aurait également
transporter des membres de votre famille
en espèces vos petits-enfants leur
nourrisse ainsi que votre votre fils
Alexandre est-ce que la police
municipale payer par le contribuable
c'est fait pour transporter la nounou de
vos petits-enfants mais vous avez vu ça
vous l'avez vu sortez ça dans le rapport
de
alors si vous croyez tout ce que tu
écris là vous êtes en train de nous
faire passer pour des gens qu'on est pas
on n'a jamais eu de problème
[Musique]
raconter n'importe quoi je connais les
méthodes je connais beau méthode les
méthodes de France
[Musique]
il avait publié un papier sur vous qui
s'appelle Gaspard Proust Éric Zemmour de
l'humour les profs 2 secondes
parce que
vous voyez rien aviez quand vous voyez
Giscard tout aviez
quand vous voyez en 75 il fait les vœux
avec un Damon
et
aujourd'hui
les Bretonnes j'imagine qu'elle aime le
quatre-quart et elle va en bouffer
beaucoup la ganache chocolat noir
écouter vos messages c'est une bonne
solution
appel en absence jamais décroché c'était
des numéro masqué la présidence
[Musique]
agréable la texture
Johnny Hallyday
et bien voilà
photos
plein de choses différentes dans le rap
américain
donc j'ai plusieurs couleurs dans mon
[Rires]
je sais pas si c'est la bonne émission
[Applaudissements]
en tout 2520 stallation lumineuse géante
prennent vie chaque soir au parc du
Ritouret jusqu'au 1er février 2022 à
la maison s'il vous plaît non non non
non non